[Musique]
et j'accueille à présent on est content
de la retrouver mélanie poquet sur ce
plateau bon soir de la rédaction tv 78
quoi de mieux pour décompresser en cette
fin de semaine cette première semaine de
rentrée pour profiter de rendez vous
originaux mélanie vous avez sélectionné
deux rendez-vous deux idées de sorties à
faire ce week-end et oui pour l'un
d'entre eux on va prendre de la hauteur
parce que le musée d'archéologie
nationale de saint germain en laye vous
propose une balade pour le moins
originale ou promenades historiques sur
les toits du château une hauteur qui
vous permet d'avoir un point de vue sur
la forêt les alentours jusqu'à l'aqueduc
de marly elles sont organisés tous les
mercredis samedis et dimanches jusqu'au
30 septembre et la réservation se fait
le jour même à la billetterie du musée
plus au sud dans le département dans le
parc naturel de la haute vallée de
chevreuse et une balade bucolique
oui c'est le musée du petit moulin qui
vous emmène là pour une randonnée de
trois heures un peu plus de 6 km pour
partir à la découverte du réseau
hydraulique des vaux de cernay à travers
six moulins à eau
certains ont bien sûr aujourd'hui
disparu mais on trouve encore quelques
traces et à l'issue de cette randonnée
le petit moulin de vaux de cernay sera
visite en accès libre pour les
intéressés pensez à réserver auprès du
petit moulin le rendez-vous grégory est
donné ce samedi 17 septembre à 14h30
merci mélanie on vous retrouvera dès la
semaine prochaine jeudi aux manettes de
l'émission 7,8 culture cette saison sur
tv 78